we have a simple message for all
countries
test test test
a simple message yes a simple solution
are not sure and certainly not all
countries have been employing it the
fight against corona virus has multiple
fronts testing tracing infection chains
racing to create vaccines and treatments
or seeing what already exists and what
could be adapted to treat the novel
coronavirus how should countries
prioritize I'm Janell de Milan
and those are the kinds of questions we
want to answer in this DW kovat 19
special it's the same one scientists and
government officials have grappled with
since at the beginning of the outbreak
now back to the message to test test and
test South Korea was one of the
countries which followed the World
Health Organization's advice most
diligently and managed to flatten the
curve here's how South Korea did it a
South Korean Hospital has created a new
system for testing patients suspected of
suffering from the corona virus ko vid
19 after an initial consultation
patients enter a booth to have samples
taken and talk to a medical technician
using an intercom song Jung Hyun had
developed a fever and other cold like
symptoms and decided to get a test just
to be safe if you don't know that you
have it the pandemic spreads even if
you're a little anxious it's good to
have a test at first I was scared when I
heard about it but it wasn't as painful
as I thought and it was actually kind of
interesting
the booths are the brainchild of dr. kim
san gil early designs were quickly put
in service on march 10th the booth
helped medical workers process patients
ten times faster than the traditional
procedure prior to the introduction of
this system patients were treated in
large negative pressure rooms which take
a long time to sterilize and ventilate
it's inefficient and doctors and nurses
had to meet people face to face and were
nervous about exposure and tired this
physical separation is safer and enables
prompt examinations dozens of hospitals
in South Korea and abroad have expressed
interest in implementing a booth testing
system although these prototypes are not
scaled for manufacturing dr. kim has
shared his know-how testing has been a
key pillar to South Korea's response to
the corona virus outbreak seeking to
flatten the curve and reduce the number
of new cases without implementing a
complete lockdown test kits manufactured
here have been exported to other
countries to strengthen their response
to the pandemic drive through testing
has also been an innovative way South
Korea has battled the corona virus
outbreak despite fewer coronavirus cases
in South Korean recent days medical
intern pock John Hsu argues for rapid
testing
[Music]
would you the number of confirmed
persons is gradually decreasing the most
important thing to get rid of the
epidemic is to identify the suspected
patients as soon as possible and have
them self isolate or receive necessary
treatment if you have even a little
fever or suspected symptoms it's
recommended that you go to the hospital
and get tested after examining thousands
of patients drive through and booth
testing have only uncovered a few cases
of the corona virus but they have
offered a lot of reassurance to a
nervous population joining me now is al
Edwards he is a professor and
immunologist at the University of
Reading in the UK welcome al now South
Korea's method seems to be working so
why aren't all affected countries doing
mass testing if they can it's a really
good question I think that the video you
just saw gives you some glimpses as to
why testing itself is a very valuable
tool but it's quite labor-intensive and
it has to be done really carefully
because if you do testing in a way that
isn't properly and safely controlled
there is a risk that you can also spread
the virus or put your health workers at
risk when they take those samples so
it's a delicate balance and it needs a
lot of manpower well because of the
complexity of this task we can imagine
that not all countries are able to
enroll this kind of mass testing what
would you recommend for those countries
so I think that the most important thing
is to spread their resource you have
wisely so what's really important is to
first of all prioritize people who are
in hospital and also healthcare workers
because these are the most vulnerable
people and also the most exposed people
and by prioritizing the use of your
testing resource and by using that as
smartly as possible even if you have
limited testing resource it's still
incredibly value and it gives you so
much data and so much information about
what's going on
what about home testing kits could they
help at all yeah so there's a number of
different technologies and tools out
there
these can even be as simple I have one
here of this little plastic cassette
that could potentially be used at home
this kind of technology is going to be
incredibly useful but it does have to be
used very carefully so when you do a lab
test you have the best possible accuracy
if you do a home test they're not quite
as accurate but they're more convenient
so you have to make sure that you use
the best possible science and medical
practice to use these tests effectively
rather than just using them without
proper consideration now testing is of
course one issue but how much of an
issue is for example global access to
vaccines and treatments going to be are
we in danger of seeing a
first-come-first-served approach which
could prioritize rich countries for
example yeah and I think that's already
happening to a degree with testing even
the the better off countries are getting
first access to testing technology and
unfortunately I could see the same thing
happen with therapies there's some
really good news and some positive news
which is that people seem to be
incredibly open to sharing the
information they have about improved
treatments and that's vital so everybody
has that knowledge but whether we can
see the same sharing of resources I'm
not so sure about whether that's
resource in terms of ventilators or when
vaccines start to be manufactured
whether people will share them around
I'm not sure whether that's going to
happen we'll have to see information
sharing as well as resource sharing it's
going to be vital thank you very much al
Edwards he is a professor and
immunologist at the University of
Reading in the UK thanks for your
insights
now vaccines seem to interest many of
you as you've been sending us your
questions in the last few days
our science correspondent Derek Williams
has some answers for you take a look
the problem with developing any
pharmaceutical product is that it has to
go through an exhaustive testing process
with the vaccine you first have to
identify good potential candidates and
that when astonishingly quickly this
time within weeks of identifying the
virus and sequencing its genome
researchers began talking about
candidates but that's just the start you
next have to test your candidate for
safety usually you do it first in
animals and then in increasingly large
groups of humans but only after a
candidate has proven safe do developers
usually begin looking at actually how
effective it is so and even if and when
your candidate fulfills all of those
criteria you still have to ramp up
production to manufacture hundreds of
millions or even billions of doses now
there are ways to speed the entire
process up a little bit for example by
by running some of those trials in
parallel rather than one after the other
but that approach has drawbacks too and
that's why most experts usually predict
that we won't have a vaccine ready to
distribute on a wide scale for at least
a year and a half medications are of
course important for limiting the impact
of the virus on patients around the
world but long term to defeat the
disease we need what's called herd
immunity and the best way to get that is
through vaccines if we don't develop
vaccines experts currently estimate that
between 50 and 70 percent of us would
have to get kovat 19 before herd
immunity kicked in and stopped the
pandemic naturally but along the way it
could potentially kill millions of
people so a vaccine offers a safe
alternative to achieving immunity in a
large percentage of the population an
ounce of prevention is really worth a
pound of cure that's why although
treatments are very important long term
vaccines are even more so
a range of potential drugs that might
one day help treat kovat 19 are being
trialed around the world but we don't
really have many results for any of them
so far the World Health Organization is
looking at three candidates in
particular that have shown some promise
first its examining the effects of
established anti malarial drugs on
coronavirus symptoms
waho sponsor trials are also ongoing for
combinations of antivirals that have
already been approved for treating HIV
and finally one of the most promising
substances as a compound called REM des
aveer it was originally developed as a
potential treatment for Ebola but it
didn't work out for that disease as well
as hoped
retrospective testing however showed
that it did affect replication in the
SARS virus so hopes are high that it
might also affect that pathogens close
relative the new corona virus the best
thing about all of these candidates is
that most or all of the development has
already been done for them so production
could be ramped up quickly if they did
prove effective in these clinical trials
we should know soon if any of them work
and before we let you go we step away
from the sobering world of tests and
vaccines to indulge in lighter fare one
restaurant in Hanoi has created the
corona burger so far only available in
Vietnam but it looks set to take off
worldwide it's a beef burger in a green
tea stained virus shaped button the
restaurant owner is delighted with his
creation he says business is good and
they'll hopefully remind customers to
wash their hands before eating
and there are Swiss confectioner's
reminding us of the season but also of
the times when chocolate Easter bunnies
are decorated with little face masks